all right is everybody ready to start
the show oh i've been ready
i'm ready to party i'm so ready
hello everyone up hello everyone and
welcome to a brand new show
called idiots and abroad i'm the board
i'm alana pierce
john smith that's rahul kohli and that
is jacob fullerton
it's correct that's all wrong from my
direction uh and i'm gonna start this
show
every month we're planning to do it
every month with the same question
john where are you right now
i'm in busan okay
is that how is that how i should i'm in
busan
[ __ ] i like young [ __ ] that's good
i'm i'm very sure get it you should get
them out of your seat do a little dance
i can't actually uh because of my so
here's the thing so i'm doing like
long-term airbnbs to get around but i'm
trying to look for an alternative for
that because those are pricier than
the local payments just renting
somewhere yeah
long term all that stuff i'm only gonna
be here for like six weeks
um i did not prioritize
lighting uh and so
in order to get good light uh my
there's a desk back there but it's
attached to the wall
here um i'm in this like weird ikea
reclining chair i'm like stuck
reclining in this thing it looks dope
actually it is dope
and then on the paradigm it's the same
model
i have a footstool with a travel monitor
uh and a bunch of wires going into it
and my microphone's strapped to one arm
and the
camera rig is strapped to the other arm
so getting in and out of this thing is
very difficult how is that solving your
lighting problem
so we could be in front of windows oh i
can show you i can
i'll be gone by the time this uh check
out that for you guys are very nice to
see you
that's very pretty that just looks like
any old [ __ ] green screen background
you
son of a [ __ ] you could be holding a
postcard in front of you
yeah it is a bit blurry maybe i am
well you went to uh korea what two
months ago now
yes maybe twentieth
you were holding on to that one what you
were hot he was hoping for this
soul has it been good for the soul it's
the old soul
i don't understand ignore it don't worry
about him
he's a diversity of by the way should we
mention that we're all uh
well except for baby boy jacob what a
nice little bev
yeah well for anyone listening
do you know how to pour the perfect
pineapple yeah you can tell people how
to do that
yeah you squeeze it you squeeze it out
now watch this
right you let it pop and you count a few
seconds
so let it pop five seconds one two three
four five and then watch this
you go there
and you follow it up just follow it up
drag
drag drag drag you're going to get so
much head
not because of your the i mean phone
both right and then just let that sit
that's it and it should mimic
the draft at the uh the pub
15 minutes for the phone to subside uh
about 90 seconds
about
this is actually going to be very
offensive to any koreans
i've got this uh wine glass and i've put
ice in it
i'm pouring my grapefruit genero soju
what the [ __ ] is soju soju is
uh also going to be this is also going
to be offensive to koreans it's
basically
uh sake but different okay but worse
i think it's rice why is the way that
you're drinking it offensive to koreans
because normally everyone does it in
groups and they have these little
they're like double sized shot glasses
they're like shot glasses but a little
bit bigger
and you pour them for each other and you
you drink them like that
i'm pretty sure drinking it in a large
glass with ice
is not how you're supposed to be doing
it white people but guess what
i'm an international man of of white
yeah you can do whatever you want
john yes because i am hungover because i
actually had fun last night for the
first time
i was staying in and doing condoms isn't
fun that's fine
yeah what the [ __ ] i had fun i had fun
wearing clothes for once
that's fair i'm wearing a dress today
because i was like not going anywhere
why do you start when you stand up
sweetheart give us a 12.
please don't thank you i don't know
which one to take us
i'll [ __ ] know which one
[Laughter]
beautiful oh amazing
um so john you've been in korea for
two months i have can i get whatever
your first impressions were do you
remember what you first thought the
first things that really stood out to
you
yeah so all on the internet
i did a lot of research i took a little
bit of korean
um and everywhere on the internet said
you know seoul is an international hub
while you're learning the language you
should still be able to get around the
city
uh and eat with english fairly easily
that is not true um
and all of the stuff i learned in my
online classes
were like it was like counting and
the names for places and no
way to actually communicate give us one
to ten in in
in korea which number system
oh well there's seconds
sheep that's like the new korean that's
what basically everyone uses except when
you're
counting the number of things or you're
talking about hours
well that is hana do set
net uh yes
yeah cool so that's very confusing so if
you wanted to say what time is it three
times it's where you guys are right now
7 23 for 12 23.
okay well 7 23 it's 11 23 for me
a.m uh 7 23 would be
uh al al gopshi
or eel il gupti so this is what happens
when somebody in
korea is happy
i'll go she no that is that is when
someone will say something to me and
i'll go oh by the way
mm-hmm oh beautiful beautiful
whew 90 seconds i have never turned on
to korea to korea
i've never forgotten one time i was in
uh france and
somebody asked me a question and i said
in french i don't speak english that's
my response
and they were like okay
and i've never forgotten that i was like
[ __ ] idiot isn't it
[Music]
there you go you nailed it yeah you say
it three times
would be do you speak english you're a
[ __ ] speak french you come
that's nice i'm pretty sure that's right
i couldn't even forgotten that i don't
know
um i moved into a new place recently and
i was like in the process of just moving
stuff from our old apartment to this new
place
and there's like a back alley where i
was parking my car
and i i've completely forgotten any
spanish i learned
like ever and this drunk guy was walking
through the alley with like a
freshly bought 12-pack of cervezas
and he started just speaking spanish to
me
and he was just people having a good
time and he gave me one
of them think you're spanish right jacob
it's happened before so that probably
was the case this
time but hey you gave me a beer you can
get away with it just put it in your
fridge
that's what i do just like rebels
see castle ego what language should they
speak in the philippines
yeah which i also don't speak
tracey jacob no but it looks awesome
right
yeah tracee is
netflix's new anime that's made entirely
uh in the philippines yeah and it's set
in manila
and the they have the is it tagalog you
said tagalog tagalog
excuse me yeah so to garlic
dub and then they had
filipino actors speaking english for the
english dub so you still
get like a filipino accent with you
that's awesome yeah i love a filipino
accent i don't know if you watched it
yet right whole but gundam hathaway on
netflix
like most of the movie takes place in
the philippines because there's a part
where they go oh i don't watch gundam
anime i have sex
i really was wondering before we even
started doing this how long it would
take before we spoke about gundam
would you like to say that about star
wars me and jacob yeah you guys have
changed now you've grown up
speaking of star wars wait hold on i
just want to say that uh
no one cares about korea sorry before i
left the country i went up and visited
everyone in l.a
and the moment i got to jacob's he's
like you want to launch a gundam italy
we did and we did which one was it
there was jazz or something yeah it was
kind of thunderbolt
it's like a shorter series sorry john
can you tell me
i'm trying to get through yeah you want
to watch
and i say okay
it's weirdly accurate which is what
doesn't make sense
i know we should i want all the
impressions of me
from now on to be there because it
sounds a bit like episode one who is
that in episode one that sounds like in
phantom menace
again say something else i say oh do the
voice again
oh uh
that's anakin okay what's what's
something you would say jacob
um something about destiny's character
and i've jerked off to every star
character that's ever existed and it's
it's my it's
on my bucket list say this ask um
does anybody want to do vault of glass
what's is that that's just different
just say yeah
does anyone want to do well
why am i coming perpetually because
you're talking about yesterday you you
can't help yourself oh okay
jacob i've been out drinking with you
twice in the last year and both times
you
destiny with your own username on
i've got two a third one's on its way
just in time for this like 90 degree
weather
oh yeah i've got those shoes i wear
their shoes like everywhere i mean i
can't talk look like
i act like look that's true i can't kick
ball and i dress like
when i catch flights do you oh john i
wanna ask you that um
does everyone have like a um a go-to
travel outfit like what is your travel
outfit what is your
what do you do because my the older
generation like my parents they dress up
like they're going to [ __ ] church or
something like that people wearing
flowers no thank you
for me i do comfort
yes i i do uh loose tea
um you know generally no underwear
the loosest clothes that i can so that
you can see
every curve wait wait wait wait
are you serious about the no underwear
thing every curve
rahul so is it for comfort or is it for
curve visibility no i i wear underwear
i wear underwear um but i take it off
for two years say i go to the bathroom i
take it off
so when i go through tsa yeah if i have
to get felt
up yeah for sure yeah but then i'll put
it back on
uh for the flight excuse me sir are you
carrying a kielbasa in your pocket
two in fact um
um i do uh yeah i mean i i yeah just
comfort
comfort 100 i'm always cold and i always
need a lot of pockets
so i wear a pair of leggings with a pair
of sweatpants over the top
oh [ __ ] and
any t-shirt and i always wear the exact
same jacket because it has the most
amount of pockets and i like the pockets
to like have a passport have an
inhaler have you know whatever else so
i'm
i always have a hood too because i like
to sleep with the hood and i'm actually
really liking from the international
flight to australia having to wear a
mask i
something about being on a plane and
having my face visible to strangers when
i sleep
makes me have trouble sleeping so now i
have a hood and a mask
way more comfortable joke's on me um i
fell asleep with a mask on my way to
korea
and uh in my sleep i mistook it for an
eye mask
so when i woke up i had my
my covered mask up on my eyes in my
mouth a gate
nobody said anything to you nope
my flight from la to sydney was the
international flight
uh i oh i was drinking a little thing of
wine
and flight attendant comes past and goes
you need to put your mask on and i was
like
even while drinking and she was like it
needs to be close to your face because i
had it in my lap
but i was so shocked that i was told
that i had to put a mask on while i was
physically like
and she was like you have to have it
around your ear
it has to be hanging from oh okay it's
just got to be oh oh okay well yeah
i always have it on my ear just because
i don't like picking things up and
putting things down it's just like a
waste of energy yeah
they said on the flight that you know
i'm vaccinated whatever but they said on
the flight
you can take it down for drinking and
eating yeah
so for about 45 minutes i just held a
bottle
and they didn't say anything because
they didn't know if i was mid-sip or
just finished one i was just like that
and then
you're just like you got it
i could have just put it on but i got
beards in it got beads in it dude
like i didn't have a beard when i came
here because my whole thing was i
i shaved my head and my face before
starting this trip
because it's a new career
what don't worry about it y'all just
keep going
okay no don't worry um
but now that i have a beard and then
it's humid and hot outside like
i had to buy thicker masks because i was
using these thin ones
and they just become translucent because
i'm sweating so much
oh no they just get yourself through
them
is it is it some of it
it is and summer here means like 100
humidity almost all the time yeah yuck
that's some [ __ ] so i'm the only one in
winter then
yeah yeah how many so how long have you
been out since quarantine now how many
weeks have you been out in korea i got
out of quarantine on june 3rd so it's
been like six weeks
what is the weirdest thing you've eaten
weirdest thing i've eaten
uh well i learned i have an allergy i've
never had any allergies
um but one night we went out me and my
this guy doug that i met out here
uh we went to a more traditional place
there
was that a korean we've got a [ __ ]
talk about doug you can't just boost the
past
he's he's a canadian that's lived here
for 17 years
uh he dm'd me well and he said wanna
smash and i said i'm straight and he
went okay well you want to hang out
and i said sure well you did i
did okay no we'll finish the allergy
story first yeah
okay so there's like traditional
traditional korean which is
uh for lack of a better term all this
crazy [ __ ] that
you know most modern people are like
what i've never seen this as a cuisine
uh and then they have these oh the more
popular places are
like they call it traditional fusion
where it's the same
kind of serving style where everything
comes
in kind of familial style and it's
korean
dishes uh but there's not like
uh i mean i don't even know you know the
different parts of the animal that
you know most people like that has kind
of gone out of vogue
on the global uh culinary
spectrum you talking about any of us
yeah
exactly um but there was this one thing
we we like asked him for a
recommendation he's like oh you should
try this
this is on korean by the way tug is
speaking korean oh dugo's
he says it's pretty salty i was like i
love salt let's get it
and then when it came it turned out what
was lost in translation was that
he meant it's like the most ocean
flavored
sea creature that exists oh my god okay
um
and it was like it might have been like
a sea slug it was something
slimy and uh but it was
in this rich like kimchi sauce so it was
good but texturally was like
i don't know sure about this um but then
on my way home i started getting an itch
in my throat
and then i when i was going to sleep i
was like
it was like coughing it's hard to
breathe oh no did you think you had
coconut and
i did i was like oh no i've covered
and then i woke up and the whole next
day i was like tired and like my lungs
were like
but then the next day i was fine and
doug was like that sounds like a food
allergy and i was like
i'm not a [ __ ] i think doug's
misdiagnosed you i think yeah you might
have covered
yeah i had hour coveted yeah it
vaccinated yeah
doug's leaning on all sorts of wrong
paths i did i had the delta
variant yep i wouldn't trust doug he's
one he
salty it was mistransl of the ocean you
had a food allergy when you had kovid
yeah well actually right before i left
well actually right after i left hongdae
which was the area of soul i was in
there was a huge covet outbreak so when
that kind of adds up
when doug dm'd you what did he
at first pose as like a 20 year old hot
cosplayer
yeah because that happened he was like
hey
what's up i'm a college student here and
i'd love to meet you
and maybe do some role-playing and i was
like
i've been reading berserk i'd love to
get up in them cuts
that was the thing that you mentioned it
at first john was that you found it
hard to meet people yeah
is that a language barrier thing mostly
or a cultural thing yeah
but also like i've been kind of stubborn
it's like i don't want to meet
other expats i want to meet koreans yeah
um
but from what i can tell most uh korean
people don't want
anything to do with people out
um and i i i'm like i'm not joking like
uh
they don't want anything to do with
white people or that like it's just
anything like anybody yeah anybody on
like just let me [ __ ] do my thing
like they have their friend groups yeah
they have their family they don't want
to meet anybody new
especially some chinese translucent
masks
um but uh so finally i
uh buckled and i went to an expat bar
called retro game bar rgb
um and i met some people there and it
was fun
uh but mostly it's been over uh social
media
the people that i've met have you been
recognized
no um that would be nice yeah what's
your like uh
i don't know i just i'm wondering if
someone could you know funhouse fans
client can
crawl out of anywhere i once had a i was
granted i was in l.a but paramedics
drove by with the sirens on and then
pulled up
and then one came out and went yo sorry
you you won the fun house stuff
and it was i don't know yeah
[Music]
wait a minute guy with sirens and then
you're like breaking
don't worry it's just a food allergy
yeah so like how often do you go out
john like just go out and
recreationally well that's something
i've been trying to put a handle on
because you're traveling you're going oh
i gotta go out i gotta see the sights
um so every night you're going out
eating
like a bunch of food and drinking every
night
uh that like i gained so much weight in
my first month
mm-hmm it's bad um so now that i'm in
busan
uh i went to the grocery store i bought
uh i i bought uh
you know some food and i've been making
breakfast and lunch and then i'll
sorry la's rubbing off on you yeah
finally
you made us you made us um what did john
make us in big brother i don't even
remember
a whole bunch of like yummy like was it
breakfast stuff it was breakfast yeah
you delicious it was good it's all good
did i did i also make dinner one time
i think so i think i was planning to
make dinner and then
yeah yeah that's right what did we order
we had these
pizzas we got a bunch of pizza oh yeah
pizza
i spent so much money uh on like dough
and topping ingredients like cheeses
different cheeses and
different pizza toppings and i was like
let's do some
pan pan baked pizza like it's so good
and you guys were like
let's judge order pizza from the store
i did that yeah
[Music]
it was like the night before that oh is
it the chicken yeah
yeah yeah it was just chicken with the
mustard
mustard so good it's great pink chicken
thank you
i woke up at night though going
like jacob just like jake but it's
because he was thinking about destiny
you wanna
that's how any time we talk about jacob
now we will have to do that version
i bumped into jacob was like and just
tongues oh can i tell you guys about the
prostitutes
yes yes yes yes yes okay
uh so there are prostitutes i have not
met any
uh not an outdated term sex workers
i believe is what you say now sex
workers i'm not actually i think
prostitute is the like clinical like
it's the technical it's
you know what legally it's ladies and
gentlemen
ladies i don't know i i you know i have
no shame in it i think destigmatize all
sex work
100 you know i've de-stigmatized [ __ ] i
often say i wish i was a [ __ ]
um that's how you're doing it yeah
uh don't have the track record to uh
claim that title you don't need the
numbers it's more it's a mentality thing
yeah it's a mental thing i have massive
slight energy
i don't have the numbers that's accurate
yes that is true um
but so okay so my first night
in seoul because i did two months in
quarantine
uh or two sorry two weeks in quarantine
and then i took a taxi out from
incheon where the airport is and where
the hotel was i'm so excited
yeah get ready disappointed um and i get
to my apartment at like
because we had the option of either
leaving it midnight of the 14th night or
in the morning and i chose midnight
so i get in my place i just get all my
luggage in and i pass out
and then i wake up the next morning and
i go alright let's check out this view
and i open the blinds and i look out
and it's mostly just other apartment
buildings but straight down in center on
the street
is a place that says ryan whiskey and i
was like
oh my god it's destiny this is literally
the only place i can see
i love whiskey i know that in japan
they have kind of uh you know they like
whiskey and cowboys and stuff
maybe that's also a thing here in korea
trust me
if i move if i go to japan i'm going to
call myself johnny and people are going
to love it
that's what all western media has told
me about japanese people
okay they also love baseball right
is it well everybody loves baseball
cree's got baseball
not everybody mate you mean you mean in
asia
uh i mean everywhere everyone in the
whole world loves baseball
um i don't know you guys are all the
right people to ask about this
you guys like condoms yeah we're not
worldly enough to answer that question
for you
the australian but so
that i'm like all right i'm just waiting
and like that the whole day i get my
computer set up to stream and everything
but i was like
the moment the night falls i'm walking
down to ryan whiskey
and i'm going to buy some nice whiskies
because
i i i figure you guys have been places
where they just have that
whiskey book of all the different types
of whiskies
from all over the world that's when they
called it a whiskey bar i thought that's
what it would be
because i've experienced those in
multiple countries
yep all around the world i've
experienced these whisky bars
so i go in immediately
notice uh four
very attractive ladies behind the par i
was like i guess that's how they do it
here in korea no dudes um i guess that's
just the thing
so i sit down and go uh i'd like some
whiskey
and she went nay i was like oh [ __ ]
um but then but then one of
the women spoke a little bit of english
and she came over
and she gave me the menu and i opened
the menu and
there were like only 12 bottles listed
or 12 types listed all for like
between 250 and 400 dollars
and i was like um so you have to buy a
bottle
hmm and initially i went can i just have
like one
one glass one shot she was like
really it's like yeah i just want she's
like
i i guess and then she started to walk
away i was like you know what
and this is another ignorance thing
because i went you know what these
prices are probably because of like
tariffs and stuff and this is probably
just how much
these bottles cost here in korea
so these aren't like exorbitant prices
this is just how much they cost
so i was like you know what actually i'm
gonna buy a bottle and i'm gonna
take it home and i'm going to have a
bottle of whiskey for the month that i'm
here
an investment an investment so i tell
her i say
you know what i'll get a bottle i'm
going to get the glenn lewitt 12 year
um and so she goes oh great awesome very
cool
uh and she brings it over and she sets
it down
and she takes out a bucket of ice too
and i go oh it's some ice i like
drinking my knee but she's got ice
uh and then she brings over this big
thing of tea
uh and she pours me a glass of tea i was
like okay
i guess this is like the chaser uh and
then she comes back over and she sits
down
and she starts opening the bottle and i
was like okay i guess she's gonna open
the bottle for me
maybe poor my first class this is
right now uh and then she takes out two
glasses
and sets them down and pours a shot for
both of us
well actually she poured a shot for her
and then handed me the ball and i had to
pour her shot
uh and then i realized that she would be
sitting with me
the whole time and then i would be stuck
with her
for the next however long until i
mustered up the courage to run away
um basically this is your pool
no it's no well this is korea no but
it's the same thing in the cabaret clubs
you have to buy the bottle and they sit
with you
that does happen in yakuza is that oh
the game yakuza yeah you gotta keep
talking
[Laughter]
i didn't get that far in yakuza i
stopped playing it uh and it turns out
it's what's called a talking bar yeah
which is that's what it is
and it's basically uh platonic
sex work because they sit there
what did we talk about was that not
helpful for korean alone in korean
no oh
so i so i had to leave my bottle there
and i ended up going
back a few weeks later after having
taken a few weeks of korean classes
which by the way i learned so much more
in class
in korea than i did over skype if you're
ever learning if hey
hey you at home if you ever want to
learn a language go to the country and
take an extensive language class don't
do [ __ ] skype over the internet
also one of my affiliate sponsor links
is an online skype
language class so don't tell them that i
said that
excellent this is going to be dual lingo
or something so you took some classes
and you went back
i took some classes and i went back and
they were just making fun of me the
whole time
oh no like i would say something they'd
go
no your korean is bad did you have the
bottom of the boat
to get locked well so i i emptied
the bottle the rest of the bottle that
second time and then they drunkenly
convinced me to buy another bottle so
yeah
oh my god when does the
when does all the it doesn't talk so
it's like
tonic it's platonic flirting
like attention that seems so in your
career you've got to pay
to be friend-zoned no i think that's a
valuable service i genuinely think that
there are a lot of people who could use
that
well that's the thing you know they say
how do they address they
they interview a lot of uh
what's the term that we're using
but sex workers that's a whole that's
the whole industry
i'm talking about escorts escorts yes
there you go but that's a lot of escorts
that said that many times
their repeat customers they won't even
have sex they'll just want someone to
talk to
yeah and be like vulnerable with yeah i
feel like it's a gateway let me tell you
something i have been this close
go on to just wanting an escort
to scratch my back really yeah
because i love having my back scratched
right and just
that's actually interesting scratch my
back and then leave i don't know
don't touch my don't touch my ding-dongs
i get upset if i go to the hairdresser
and they don't give me a good head
yeah it's not their job that's a thing
oh my god they got
like so hard on it it's amazing and if
they don't do it i'm like i don't feel
like i should be paying full price
you're basically getting a massage at
their hairdressers
me i should just buy a prostitute to
hold me and stroke my hair
i think you can get an aspect to do that
yeah but
dude the thing is you're going to end up
you're going to end up being like
yeah yeah yeah i won't yeah i
won't be able to not do that how were
they
how would the how were they dressed what
was the what was that they were
very tight short dresses so there was
still a visual element to it like
there was a direction well it's supposed
to be flirty i imagine it's not it's not
actually it's
already yeah okay but i do have to tell
you my first time there
initially uh the woman and she spoke
enough english that we could communicate
um uh she initially sh
i was asking her question she's like no
no i need i need to ask you questions
because i think
it's like an ego stroking thing
initially but then we got through
uh i think two-thirds of the bottle that
night
um and at one point she was just
rambling on and on about all this
different stuff
uh one thing and this i'm not
using this term i'm just relaying what
she said
uh because i was very confused um
she said and once again this is what she
said
she's like i learned english from all of
my banana friends
and i said what did and i thought i
misheard her and i was like
wait what she said banana i said are you
saying
banana and she said yes and then she
explained that that's because
uh yellow on the outside white on the
inside
that's what that means and i was like oh
okay i don't think i'm allowed to say
that so that but that would be
that would be koreans well it's like
that's koreans that like
grew up in the states and then now live
in korea
they would use that term like in for us
like south asians that would call
like call me a coconut it's the same
brown on the outside
[Laughter]
but yeah so she she said that's how she
learned
all her english just from hanging out
with her american korean friends
um and uh and then she started telling
me
about how she's bisexual and she was
hitting on a girl
in a club because we were talking about
how uh
like that's not uh
like it's it's not taboo like you're
allowed to be
uh you know not straight uh
but it's
i guess it's kind of it's it's not it's
not super chill
people around the pond still about it
not like fragile
but not yeah
but then so we were talking about that
and she's like you know me i'm bisexual
and like i love women and one time i was
in this bar
and um like i was hitting this girl and
she wanted to bring her boyfriend in the
mix and like i was like no i just want
you and like her boyfriend came over and
i was so scared of him he was so scary
i was like what was scary about him she
was just like he was
he was just so scary and i was like what
was scary about him
it's like just the way he looked and he
said and i went
was he black and she went yes oh my god
and then
for like way too long
she was telling me about how scared she
is
and i was just sitting there i was
sitting there with i guess you've paid
for this
i've paid for this and more than a third
of a bottle of whiskey in my body
just going mm-hmm
[Music]
well i guess i'm gonna go my issue with
it is that like i i hate talking about
this kind of thing and being like
oh cringe when none of us are black like
for any black people who'd be listening
it's way worse for them and i'm always
like i'm just so sorry
that this happens on a global scale it's
[ __ ] awful and oh god
this is the world that we're in but i
don't know what the teaching moment is
there either
you're like okay well that's racist
[ __ ] i don't know how uh hanging out
with prostitutes john
is the just pour my bottle of whiskey
[ __ ] control i
i'm gonna issue ten apologies on episode
one
so yeah what was yours john called me
john john said i was a coconut
he did say you're a coconut no i didn't
cancel i just said you
are i did not speak the full sentence
uh so do you have to finish the whole
drink there or can you
take the bottle away no you can like you
can't take the bottle home but i was
able to leave it
okay oh we'll come back to it yeah and
then i came back a few weeks later yeah
but then of course they left enough that
we had enough of the bottle left that by
the time i finished it
they drunkenly convinced me to get
another bottle oh
so hold on can you have three women
leaning into a table going come on like
just buy it
and i'm okay i guess i will
so can you pick what woman sits with you
or you probably you probably could but
i don't know probably but
i think when i was there there weren't
many people
in there it was just like a couple dudes
the first time and then no one the
second time
so they all sat with me in the second
well i guess that's why when at first
you were like i just want a shot they
were like
[ __ ] rude that would be like not
giving someone a tip
you'd be like wow okay jackass you just
want to take a shot with me for a minute
yeah yeah that's yeah but funny enough
uh in my place in busan it's this big
big big building and there's a bunch of
stores on the first three floors there's
like four bars
and i was like you know what i'm gonna
go to each bar and have a little drink
at each part check out the vibe of each
bar
the first one i go into there's just
it's just
this it's the same thing whether it's
just attractive women and i went uh
hanjon which is uh one dream
and she's like oh yeah and she's whiskey
yeah whiskey and she opens the menu and
it's just bottles and i went
anio and i just ran out
that means no sorry i just ran out
because it was the exact same thing and
then i didn't want to go to any of the
other bars
how are you supposed to know which ball
is a like a regular bar and which ones
are like
friendship i don't know you already
you're getting too deep you think he's
just too late
yeah because this one this one busan had
everything they had wine they had beer
and they had
whiskey and then
you tell by the people that are visiting
right you look around and if it's
predominantly
here's the thing i don't know if if like
i'm just not going out late enough
because supposedly
uh koreans are very much night owls
that's what i've been told i love that
this is how we spread
you know how stereotypes spread like
indians love curry and then you'll hear
someone go
you know koreans night owls this is this
is part of the concept of this show
is to talk about where john is in the
world uh and it's korea we don't have a
korean talking about it
yeah oh i'm like drifted in sweat over
here i realized i turned my ac
off i'm just sweating you look great
so we can you can see we can get the
full oh yeah
image of what it was like i i wanna ask
something though
in every country wherever i go one of
the first things i try in a new country
is mcdonald's
yes because it does change from
the country and it's it's awesome
because australia
so mcdonald's hits every time right
because it's a formula so to see it
deviate it's so wild because it is
probably one of the most consistent
chains dd8
what i'm holding up the dda oh dv8
um so have you tried any american fast
food have you tried a mcdonald's have
you tried anything staple like a
starbucks that's basically all i've
eaten i have not gone to any korean
restaurants
i'd heard so much about everybody says
oh the mcdonald's
in other countries is so much better
than in america like they put
it's mo it's better quality and it's
just better
that's not the case here oh okay i got a
i got a double bulgogi burger okay okay
oh
that sounds good you don't know what
this means yeah
it means it's cow meat gogi is
meat and bulgogi is bull meat so it's a
hamburger
uh different i think it is
different cows i don't
know if the meat is different though i
have no idea no
you milk yeah you know you're right it's
a different sauce or something
female and as well as male but i have no
concept of if they're meat no
bulgogi it's not a bull it's just a boom
it's bulgogi okay
[Laughter]
that's that's still just beef
i think so i'm not actually sure yeah
it was all right but it was just
i mean it was still sloppy like it
didn't it wasn't more aesthetically
pleasing
it did it wasn't like oh my god these
quality it was just fast food jacob have
you been to the philippines
no i've only i've eaten plenty of
filipino food at like my grandparents
and stuff
but i've never actually been there oh
even i've been there
whatever but have you been to over has
anyone been to other country mcdonald's
well i mean i've been to
japanese mcdonald's and they have
teriyaki burgers and they're [ __ ]
delicious
it's almost like uh you know you get
your cheeky
um chicken chicken mayo yeah like the
tiny ones cheap they have
the teriyaki buggers that'll like that
um but they also
ciders cream pies they sell that are
called
spicy you wanted a cream pie
is not a cream pie john yeah is on the
outside
he's on the [ __ ] face john um but
mcdonald's in australia is pretty next
level so
and it was really interesting coming
back to australia and seeing ads
uh there are so many ads here that are
targeted against uh domestic violence
like all the time ads um but the
mcdonald's in australia
yeah because it's a huge problem here um
like a massive issue
uh but the mcdonald's ads are all
focused on coffee because australia is
such a
excessively pretentiously coffee
drinking
country it's all your flat whites and
your lattes and your cappuccinos we
don't do like
cold brew oh yeah it's like it's a very
significant culture so i love that the
australians think like
aren't the italians the ones though like
i have australians decided now
we know that they're so good though well
no it's not that we're saying we know
more about
do you use kangaroo milk exactly it's
just that our coffee culture is very
specific and it's like
rivalries between states who thinks they
have the better coffee in the different
states it's a huge thing
but the coffee in australia in my
opinion at mcdonald's is better than the
coffee
at any [ __ ] place i've ever been to
in the u.s
it's so good but i mean you can get
better at just like a
any coffee shop you go into do they have
a lot a big range do they have like
everything pretty big yeah but i think i
mean they all have the cafes in them and
all the cafes do like proper coffees
where
the us they all suck but i mean it's the
mint cafe
yeah not mccafe i did cafe
i did a lot of traveling when i was
younger it kind of slowed down
as i got older for some reason but i was
very fortunate because i've got a lot of
family in various parts of it
you're from [ __ ] europe too you'd all
you
yeah that was awesome get on a train
sure i mean i'm
i'm on an island surrounded by water
i've been to new zealand
no you want a peninsula surrounded by
communist
democratic dictatorship there it is
you're right i mean it is cheating when
you're from the uk like
it takes what three and a half hours to
drive to vegas
yeah you can be in france in two hours
on a train
so it is you know but but i meant like
asians
frogs there's no you in france you
dip it's also not flames it's france
france francais not france
you make it sound like i'm saying i say
france that's something i've been
curious about how does every country
actually call their country
because isn't in japan it's like nippon
or something
yeah it's completely different they
don't call it and then here in korea
guess what it's called hangu they call
that country hangu
hanguk but it's germany's deutschland
right
deutsche yes that's it sorry yes it's
deutschland it's australia well
australia but a lot of a lot of
foreign countries call it australian
like there's an n on the end
we call it the united kingdom
or great britain
that's what we do um do you want to
finish your story about your traveling
oh yeah yeah yeah so so my mom
so what about oh it's very good so my
mom
my mom's family or my great-grandfather
emigrated to thailand so my grandfather
and my mother are
both born in thailand and from there
siblings had moved to like malaysia
indonesia
and so as a as a as a kid i got to
visit family around those areas and the
best
like americanized fast food chain i've
had in a foreign country
was thailand's kfc
was incredible and i don't know what it
was it was ju
even the most basic stuff was just on
another level their chicken
the mcdonald's was okay what was your
go-to order for
kfc kfc i think i was having nuggets
they had like these
nuggets that were just incredible just
yeah but the kfc there i remember
i also did mcdonald's in morocco um
and most of their stuff is replaced with
lamb
so your big mac is a lamb
big mac instead of beef cultural thing
but it still tasted amazing
we uh our mcdonald's here they don't all
do it
but uh some of the larger ones will
serve you
like your mcdonald's on one of those
like wooden platters with a
your chips are in like one of those
baskets like that looks like a deep
fryer basket
like a fancy like bougie cafe um you can
get halloumi
uh you can get like you know anything
with like you can beetroot and like
pineapple in some of the burgers their
menu is way bigger and they have healthy
options like
actual extensive healthy options
mcdonald's here is so different to the
us that
all i'd want in the us is nugs just give
me 10 nuggets
louise had nuts jacob yeah that's how
you said nuts too
jacob do you remember jbx jbx
no maybe it was just everything
uh alana you're talking about fancy
mcdonald's
guess what mcdonald's is just ripping
off jack-in-the-box
because back in like 2004
jack-in-the-box converted multiple
jack-in-the-box
locations to jb x's
and what were they they had fireplace
inside them
they had fancier ingredients aren't they
fancy taco bells that have balls in them
what are there yeah i think there are
tacos all i know is that all of the jbx
is converted back to normal jack in the
boxes within nine months
yeah why because we recently
no one cared eating taco bell yes
the uh what's it called supreme crunch
roll [ __ ] great
i i basically had cream crunch wrap
supreme
that's the hexagon right oh my god it's
so good it's fantastic yeah the
breakfast crunch wrap is the best i've
survived after that for like nine months
it's like it's a textural delight
there's a lot it's a crunchwrap except
there's a hashbrown eggs
either bacon or ham
and cheese and a sauce
you know what you know what's king it
still hits every denny's
denny's gets me oh baby don't go to
danny sober though
yeah that's that's that's the the
display
disgusting sure yeah it's on your
birthday right they compete on your
birthday do they do that
denny's yeah you sure he's getting a
fake license
every day that's gonna be more expensive
than your daddy's order
be like oh oh here hold on it's my
birthday let me
let me let me take out my id figure out
which one it's a full filing cabinet
with bruce a lot of a lot of
post-drinking you know why you know why
because it's new because
yeah because denny's was two blocks away
from his house that is absolutely wrong
with everyone yeah no matter where we
were
to go to that denny's it's true and we
did it and we all did it we did do it
i called the same stunt when i got you
guys oh yeah to come to my english pub
but really
it's awesome we went to like a drink at
that star wars bar and then we
drove 20 minutes to go eat chicken
near you oh my god 24 hot that's not
that close to you is it raffle
no that wasn't i wasn't pulling that
[ __ ] there i was i was off my
i just still love that johnny yeah i
don't know a lot of alana had to what i
pee
i wonder about milk it's hot chicken i
need milk
i just yeah you went in oh god
that was fun away for our food
is the food spicy in korea i don't
really have much korean there it is
stuff here yeah i haven't had anything
that was too spicy though
have you done korean barbecue do they
just call it barbecue
it's just barbecue but yeah i've done it
actually it's just called barbecue
there's no korean what do they call it
they call it korean barbecue
oh there's a word for it
like they don't call old boy a korean
movie it's just a movie
yeah well actually trendy busan the
movie is just called busan
[Laughter]
that's true i think actually
have you been to like an internet cafe
or a gaming cafe or anything like that i
went into one
because i was looking for an hdmi cable
i went in and i i said uh
hdmi audie
yo which means i thought it meant where
can i buy an hdmi cable
um because sa sada is to buy
uh and audi a is where so aries sayo is
where can i buy
um and you say the word of the thing you
want first
at the first yeah at the beginning of
the sentence so you're saying hdmi where
do i find
yeah okay uh
and he's like what
uh and then eventually he understood
what i was saying but i realized that
there are so many pc they're called pc
bongs
um like because bong is broadcast
like i tell people uh video game bong
uh which means i stream video games
uh do people generally know what that is
i imagine that yeah yeah
they go away wow
did you tell the girls at the speak at
the at the the tournament
video games
i told her that i like did youtube and
twitch she didn't know what twitch was
like oh i'll show you my youtube
and i took out my phone and i skipped um
i did the it was that nintendo
peripherals video i have
oh yeah but i skipped specifically to
the part where it's me on the green
screen dancing
crazily with the snes mouse and i just
brought it up and i showed it to her
and she was just like
[Laughter]
okay you must have looked
psychotic yeah i was also drenched in
sweat
it was just like dripping you should
have you should have shown her um
oh she wouldn't have understood you
she wouldn't know about it there's two
of the two of the four people in that
video can't even speak
normal english one is it
which one is it i know he's still good
he's definitely he's talking about me
and jacob it's a racist comment that's
what i'm asking
he's talking about the indian and the
filipinos
a terrible
what's your impression of me i feel like
i deserve one too
yeah we've already got two of them
too you're irish that's so old that's
not irish
that's australian australian yeah oh
dingo it's my baby
incredible very good that is very
accurate
um
when he does impression of me you you
look sleepy when you do it like
i don't realize low energy
[Laughter]
you cross your eyes too oh do i
oh morocco oh my god i don't know which
one's which
it's crazy very good jacob by the way
i've been using that beard oil ruffle
oh yeah in the beard brush still using
it
mm-hmm give them a shout
i don't know what they're called can you
handle god i want beer
i don't know why i said it without an h
jacob i think you're doing well so i was
gonna ask what's
what's like you said you've eaten a lot
of filipino food what is general
philippine what's the most traditional
filipino dish [ __ ] i think like other
than
other than [ __ ] which we know jacob is
drowning in yeah
i'll take a bite off jacob's lupia yeah
it's uh yeah lupia that's the big one i
mean the [ __ ] loop here
lumpia you never had lumpia before
really it sounds like all right
sorry glass noodles that sounds like a
flavor
no it's like they're like fried like
like it's like a fried like egg roll
kind of thing
like really fried like really crispy
yeah i want it yeah
like that's the best part is it it's
like are you in just from the fried
chicken
really fried really fried yes
and like usually when like family would
make loopy and stuff it'd be like
please lean back please get away olympia
like
it's so good what else is what else is
the philippines
uh like adobo like chicken adobo oh yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah there you go
but jacob you're mixed race right yeah
so what's what do you get on the other
side white bologna sandwiches
i guess it's uh cheese sandwiches
mayonnaise
yeah if you want to if you guys want to
like
season it my dad is a building manager
and i told rahul that he had organized
this meet and greet thing that he does
every month for all the residents
of his building and he like gets a nice
restaurant for them and like organizes a
meet and greet and
rahul said sounds about white and i was
like my dad's put effort into this
what does that mean and he was like it's
gonna be only white people
and there's gonna be cheese so i went
it's gonna be she got
really annoyed she was super friendly so
i was like my dad's hard work
it just sounded like the whitest [ __ ]
i've ever heard she was like
all the people in the residential area
are going to come and i was like it's
going to have loads of white people
there's going to be cheese no cheese
there's going to be no people are
covered she did not have any cheese and
you got
so annoyed anyway continue
well
that when you got annoyed at me i said
the cakacity of it
did say that too so you've got you've
got sounds about white
and the cakacity of it caucasian
it's what you say where the caucasians
are listen rahul
i don't think that alana me and sort of
jacob need to apologize for being white
[Laughter]
sort of jacob um
and it was only one and i got a text
later on but there was no cheese
no cheese all right i was wrong about
cheese what are there any people of
color what the [ __ ] were people coming
together for
it's true wait it was a turkish
restaurant was there halloumi no
there was no cheese [ __ ] off no there
was no halloween there was no cheese
with a wet towel scrubbing people down
everyone was white there was nobody in
what telescope people down
it was uh very strange because obviously
i came home because my sister had a baby
uh her name's
madeline and she's very cute and she's
doing great
and i'm just pretty sorry
but the weirdest thing about you know
hanging out with my sister now when
she's got a pram
is the amount of [ __ ] people who just
like poke their faces in it
it's so weird to me like they don't ask
they just go oh a baby
and it's like you don't know this person
what the [ __ ] are they doing but that's
the same [ __ ] with dogs that annoys me
when you when people like touch other
people's dogs you better believe when
i've got a dog
if i'm in an elevator and some [ __ ]
like hey billy and starts grab i'm like
that's like my child
excuse me dogs belong to the world yeah
you know what i do from now on to prove
to you you're going to torture your dogs
because they're going to want attention
from strangers and then you're going to
be like nah [ __ ] you're mine that's a
[ __ ]
let me [ __ ] tell you something let me
tell you something from now on i'm going
to bring dog culture to toddlers if i
see
a toddler with their mum or their dad in
an elevator i'm gonna walk up to the
toddler start scratching it under the
face
look how [ __ ] beautiful your son is
okay
that's my point what breed is this what
mix is this what breed
so as you guys know i am developmentally
challenged but
i did develop early in life and then i
can remember
like i felt like a normal person when i
was like four years old
and so i had to endure that for so
long being a speech
people coming up putting their faces in
me and talking to me like
yes yes treat me speak to me
normally they're foreign
yeah but also maybe i just have because
it seems like a lot of people don't
remember
way into their early childhood no i
don't maybe no i think that's how
all children feel like because
a person will be going oh hey like hey
judy how's it going oh here's your son
hello window guy it's like why'd you
just change the way that you're speaking
because you're talking about dogs people
yeah but okay
but dogs don't they love it no they
don't know no no no no no john
doesn't get it john's point here is are
we all
treating babies in a way that or young
kids in a way that makes them
uncomfortable
but they just we just don't remember how
uncomfortable we are because that is the
time
yeah yes and they don't have the social
like like
you know they don't know how to buck
back to authority at that young age that
they just take it
no i disagree when you meet a child
and you're like you bring your your
enthusiasm like with my godson
like with apollo like when you if you if
you're a bit more energetic and just
like yeah
i mean that's they do go a bit
no that's a bit much like i remember my
one of my great aunts like
i didn't like i like the auntie's
kissing and like you'd have to go around
the room and you're like ah [ __ ] off oh
my god
i hated that [ __ ] but my grandma tries
to kiss me on the lips
oh yeah i always love you
that's just like snap for a little bit
she goes for a mouthful
everybody just sort of you know and
then you just maybe she'll get here and
it's
i still don't like it i don't like
kissing now you just gotta make sure it
lands somewhere else exactly i don't
i don't like the adult that's one of
those weird things we do right
especially especially as men
and i'm glad i'm glad we don't have to
do this crap anymore which was
you'd shake dudes hands right if you had
a family get to
something you'd be like hello are you
doing nice to meet how you doing to your
family
and then you'd see yeah my hand hello
yeah i got i
don't know it always goes and then you
really aunties aunties
and then so it was like a gender-based
greeting that that changed and you still
i think people still do that
no i just hug everyone you'll see it
like in
like i don't know it's uh
well yeah but yeah but we told you i
have massive [ __ ] energy
don't no one should be if anyone gets
attention from me it shouldn't go to
your head
everyone gets it even the children in
the elevator
would just crash oh you're so cute
i would [ __ ] love to do that just to
see a parrot's face just do the
bring the dog energy to toddlers
well you do the permission thing you see
like oh can i touch him
yeah no but it did genuinely happen all
the time it was so bizarre to me being
with my sister as normal and then just
having complete strangers walk up and be
like how old
like who the [ __ ] are you would you
rather
you take a bait kick a baby in the head
right it won't die but kick a baby in
the end with everything you got
i promise you won't die or set a puppy
on fire
no i'm not answering it can't do that no
kick a baby of course yeah lightly
no no no you have to do with all your oh
with everything you got i don't go out a
lot though listen
it's fine i actually the fact that some
people will
choose to harm a baby
instead of killing a pup it's not about
that
it's not about that what is it listen
one time i got high and i tried to make
my own fireworks and i burned
my hands off and i've also
gonna be related okay wait what's the oh
okay he's he's talking about being
burned and being kicked in the head
okay a stroll
down the promenade my friend yeah fire
lasts yeah he's right because
you burn all your skin off and then all
those nerve
endings are just exposed to the air
that's right and whenever air touches it
it hurts
and you are in constant pain until all
those nerve endings die
and then you're fine but i it takes a
while you need skin grafts and [ __ ]
like it's awful they would put that i
didn't have health insurance i just
i just bought neosporin and creamed my
hands up and
taped them down what you trying to make
fireworks
yeah i can't open my left hand as high
as i can what
how is this making fireworks thing
happen what's this well back in the
cowboy days of youtube there were videos
of how to make
i was trying to make a smoke bomb but um
the issue was that it's
let's just say it's like three or four
different ingredients
and one of them is the retardant the
baking soda is the retardant which slows
the burn
and because i was high i forgot the
retardant oh no
so instead of having a slow burn uh
it was a very fast burn so what you did
you make a it was like this like paste
inside of a saucepan
uh and then you took a toilet paper roll
and you kind of put it in there
and then you i did a sharpie to make a
funnel so you basically have a funnel
no no no no oh the air gets sucked
through and it's basically that's what
causes it to spout and
uh and so i did that and then i was like
all right gotta test it
before i make more so i took it outside
and just lit it and immediately i was
like i was like trying to light it it
wasn't lining and then the moment it
went and it started spraying like a
giant
sparkler and i was like oh [ __ ] um
and you know how when you have a like a
garden hose
and you try to push it down into cement
and there's that like
the pressure like you can never actually
hold down yeah
i turned it over and i tried to you know
in my panic
i tried to like put it out on the ground
and i put it down and that same thing
happened where it was sliding around
and there was like these black lines um
and then the whole thing lit on fire
uh like the whole toilet paper roll and
everything and it burned my hands and i
went
and i let go of it and then started
spinning and i was up on a balcony
and on the on the ground level in the
backyard
all dead leaves the entire thing just
dry dead leaves um and this is where
it's like that could have been
real god yeah i don't know about god but
some some
force some universal force exists
and they gave me a free pass because
this thing was spinning all around
and then the the corner post
it's spinning all around and then and it
and it perfectly slams into the corner
and it's just stuck there and it's going
and it did that for three more minutes
until it burned out dude you could have
burned a house down
yeah yeah is that your daughter my hands
off i asked uh play watch listen this
uh last week what i've done
everyone has a dumb one
jacob what's your dumbest industry i
haven't gotten like
horribly hurt i do like i have a vivid
memory from being really young
and getting you know those like dancing
like ribbons that you dance with
on like a stick yeah yeah yeah i
remember getting like
tangled up in one and falling down the
stairs
oh shoot i was dancing with it it's so
vivid in my head the falling down the
stairs part
it
just
he's dancing with the gymnastic [ __ ]
things yeah that's my story that's my
tail
i got a tail of my dancing ribbon and i
fell down the stairs
alone is crying that's where we wanted
to get with this podcast right
holy [ __ ] did you stay wrapped up in it
like you fell
like yeah
and how did this happen that's where my
room was at the top of the stairs and i
was in the hallway
it was a pretty long staircase i rolled
all the way down were they carpeted
staircase or was it
hardwood it was a carpet the body wasn't
carving you're lucky what was that you
were a light saber
you were lightsaber fighting with your
those ribbons yeah but like if a
lightsaber had a rainbow
coming off of it what injuries did you
sustain did you break anything or
no it was just horribly bruised i can't
i'm not dirty though
how are you real it doesn't make sense
i'm just having a good time oh my god
she's having a good day were you doing
it by yourself yeah
i mean my parents were home but i was
upstairs alone
i love it roll down the stairs tangled
up i have a couple of injuries
you can only pick one it's not rahul's
injury cast
well i don't know which one to pick
because they're all stupid
the way your pose your chair just says
do
you don't like doo-doo
there you go
i pick one i broke my knuckle
punch in a wall a door when liverpool
or crystal power yeah that's you're
going to try that's good
but i broke my knuckles
this one happened recently so i have to
censor some of it because it could have
spoilers in it so
on midnight mass um
what's that surprise a show i did
how does it end
where all do you play note the um
time code right now just in case i ask
you to cut all this out
so we had um
set food decor decorating a a shop
so it had real convenience store items
like candy and chips and stuff like that
but by the time
we shot this scene it would have been
what four months and it was outdoors
and i that day had this monologue giant
monologue
um um i was acting like you know
you know those people in the office when
it's their birthday they don't want to
[ __ ] work they become super entitled
they're like
got the tiaras on all the crap their
chairs have got balloons and they're
like
it's my [ __ ] birthday i'm not here to
work i was like what the [ __ ] happens in
england it's a thing for sure
it's your birthday you come in and every
and you just abandon work for a day and
there's cakes and
you just have this [ __ ] i don't wanna i
didn't come here to [ __ ] work out
so i had that attitude with with mike
flanagan and everyone
where i was like it's my monologue day i
do i [ __ ] want you understand
i will smoke way too close to set i will
not adhere to the guidelines it's my
monologue day
and there had been this thing that we
were dealing with on set which was you
know people stealing the set food and
they're like this is
this is set dressing i know that there
are doritos right there
go to craft services stop stealing from
the store
people are eating it people just eating
it so i got all
a bit bright my with this wonderful a.d
morgan
and he was the one who's like been
telling everyone can you stop [ __ ]
eating the set food
after my monologue i got my chest puffed
out and i was like that's what you
[ __ ] get done my [ __ ] monologue
you understand you know what my name is
and in front of morgan i was like you
see these skittles you see these you
know what i'm going to do these [ __ ]
skittles mate
i'ma steal them in front of you and
you're going to do nothing about it
because it's my monologue day
and i took the skittles out did it put
it in
smashed my crown completely broke it on
the first bite of a skittle
in front of him after giving all that
and i just went
and a whole [ __ ] crown was just
sitting there
and he was looking at me did they have
to postpone the monologue
no we carried on i was like okay i'm
okay and then it went around there's
this like cautionary tale of why you
don't [ __ ] with the food
those skittles were like little pebbles
and i just weird
crack oh my god the that's
maybe my favorite thing
in the entire world is
when people like garner an
audience for their own injuries yeah
like like you're standing on the pool
like begging people
to jump off into the pool
yeah one time dude one time you go
thank you one time rahul was playing no
no no no no you go
no thanks i am trying to um one time
rahul was playing red dead redemption
two in front of me and he was like
yeah you know watch this and then he
takes my horse um and runs it into a
fence and
kills the horse and the character
immediately after not on purpose
he was like no watch this and he [ __ ]
kills both of them
in a second in at that point
i had never because i i've sunk
hundreds of hours into red dead i have
never in my life
seen the horse and player die on instant
impact immediately
no idea how i did it it was alana was
struggling with something and i was like
i [ __ ] got this i don't think i was i
think you tried to tell me i was but i
was you look like you were struggling
so i took it and then literally dude
within like
10 seconds it just went right into
something and it just went
and dead wasted that horse dead all of
it
yeah but that's not an injury what are
you saying about garning an audience
well that's the point is when somebody
sets something up yeah
you'll watch this um my
brother was having his like 16th
birthday or something
and so there were a bunch of like hot
high school boys
over at our house and so my sister
who's like three years younger was just
like you know
going crazy like you know so many cute
boys
let me get the ribbons yeah yeah jacob
was there
i was i was at this birthday party yeah
he's a hired clown
the ribbon clown um but my dad
had grown a bunch of habaneros and so
everyone was in like the living room
hanging out and stuff
my sister goes hey everybody watch
this and everyone turns and looks and
she has a habanero and she goes
yeah and then she had the juice on her
and she went
she rubbed her face and [ __ ] red streaks
your eyes started puffing up
and she had to go to the emergency room
and it was
the funniest thing that i'd ever seen i
was nine years old
and i like it was like this is
i feel like it's my birthday you you
were blessed that day
yeah it is good
i was trying to impress everyone at this
spanish pool when i was like
11. they were like what was spanish 16
year olds
well we were just in spain on a family
holiday okay that tracks
yeah and we took we were english you go
to spain yeah so we're at this pool
and there was these spanish girls that
me and my cousin had actually like
initiated contact with and they were
older than us but me and my cousin were
you know
we just went over and they became our
friends so we started hanging out with
these locals
every day and then i was getting a bit
boosted
you know when there's girls around and
you're trying to impress everyone
and i wanted to do a flip or i was going
to run in and do a dive into the pool
and the i [ __ ] slipped
so hard before i hit the pool and i was
quite a chubby kid so it was just tits
and flab
i [ __ ] whipped on the side in front of
everyone
but i didn't take it well the
embarrassment i thought how do you how
do you get over this you should stand up
and laugh and be like
that's badass right and then go on with
i cried i shouted i accused other people
and i might
have stormed off
no it was the it was the edge of the
pool you know the slippery side so i
didn't even hit the water
and then you blamed other people
[Music]
my group of girls i was friends with in
high school we used to
just because it was funny make anything
a competition
and then boys would do all of it if you
found a way to make like cleaning up
after a party a competition
they would [ __ ] do it it doesn't
matter yeah didn't matter what it was
if you made it a competition between the
boys they would do
[ __ ] anything and we'd just sit there
i think that still applies
i don't think that's yeah one of the
best things about playwatch listen is
that somehow we've made it a competition
to see who gets me their audio file
fastest
which as the producer of that show is
brilliant i'm like
oh no oh one of you is going to be later
than the other
they all get them to be exactly on time
all right rules
but the three of us hate women so you
can't play that probably with you guys
yeah the three of us are known in cells
yeah yes
well no i'm a ball cell what the [ __ ]
that voluntary syllable
oh yeah i'm a giga cell no you're a giga
chad i don't think you can
chat that's what you said yeah i know
all these terms quickly
i'm what's known on the streets as a
giga chad i'm actually what's known as a
chad preet what was it oh there's
chad but there's also curry cell yeah
i'm a curry you're either a curry cell
or oh my god there are so many
yeah that's an indian dude grinder
you'll see all the subsets there are for
uh
men really
yeah i signed up for grindr one time uh
just for fun
and it was like what what type of
gay are you or i i don't know what it
was who's doug
and that's how i met doug but
um there i was going through and you
know it was just like
daddy bear uh you know twink uh but then
it was like
silver daddy polar bear um
many others i just remember silver daddy
makes sense
silver daddy is like what i want to
is that's like my superhero name silva
daddy yeah i would recommend most people
want to be silver daddy
i i heard that i was a cub too
that's a bear cub or something like that
cub is like a bear but you're not you
don't have enough mass
to be oh you're like a little you're
literally what's a wolf cub
isn't that a wolf i don't think you'd be
a car bravo
you're you're really tall yeah you're
tall
you'd be an otter what is it that sounds
like something whatever
that does sound like something familiar
what's the otter
otter is they are among the bear
community in that they're they're like
hairy and into hair
but they are more have an odder body
frame
okay so it's hairy but yeah but lanky
you know the common mystery concept
yeah i'm not that hairy really yeah me
either
i hear that you little jacob trying to
grow his beard
look at my hair everyone thinks crazy
just said he's like a little sausage
look at him
i got nothing smooth as butter and just
as soft
it's also like your skin there yeah
you're pretty happy yeah i'm not gonna
join in on this i hope you guys
understand
oh my nipples are we gonna band
it's not going on twitch it's fine
that's fair i'm covered in it
hairy everywhere when jacob wore
i don't know if you remember on my
birthday jacob wore his jedi costume and
at some point he
it just turned into slightly different
yeah for sure
yeah and i thought he at that point i
was like jacob waxed
for for this my bad for you yeah
i mean i did but yeah honestly this
might be
i i feel like can i ask you a question
can i ask you a question
is all women yeah i will answer on
behalf of all women i've been nominated
and this is only because what we were
just
about us hairy men is it true that all
women
have hairy nipples but they just pluck
them
no i definitely don't have hair
no really no
oh okay did doug tell you that well i
guess i've met some weird women
no i would think
people who have hairy nipples are
probably people who have like darker
hair maybe on their arms or their legs
women also don't have hairy buttholes
no uh yes they do
i would i would think it would depend on
like
the hair on my arms is all blonde and i
imagine that so it might be less
apparent
not having hairy dips which is fine no
body shaming we love your hairy nipples
yeah well it's true i got hairy nipples
dude for some reason like my all of my
body hairs and normal length
the nipple hairs same like ridiculous
yeah it's like i'll be i'll be sleeping
i'll be like what's poking me in the eye
oh it's a nipple that's what definitely
came oh my god this is good this is
i hey this is going on my youtube
channel and
we're also going to scratch it but i
just want to say this is great content
for me you guys it's a huge win for me
i have this one hair that you probably
can't see no it's not there right now it
grows from my forehead like right here
because it's gross that long but it's
gorgeous but it's
white it's like a little antenna it's so
weird oh my god that's why would you
tell us that elana gross i won't even
notice it's there until i'm like oh i
should probably
it's a bit long i should get rid of it
it'll go like that long and it's
completely right
you know what breaks my heart last two
years three years
i've been sprouting really thick dark
hairs
in my ears and i'm like okay so i'm
gonna be that dude when i'm older i'm
that dude all right
it's all just coming out yeah you got
the toughs coming out because it's not
light it's like
really uh i pluck them and it's what is
that
i wonder if maybe you shouldn't pluck
them because it it does it not serve a
purpose to like keep your ears safe
no it's just old no because it's not
like a bunch of hair it's not like a
like a
inside of a dog's ear right it's just
like
rogue hairs yeah it's just rogue black
like so and it happens to older guys
your hairs get eerier your hair's
[Laughter]
oh i getting think i have anything
exciting in my ears no jacob you just
saw
butter not yet smooth and soft sweet
your [ __ ] [ __ ] must be
gorgeous oh my god yeah it's like a
golden egg
like a crevasse it's like it's like one
of those cadbury eggs
yeah the inside right rahul
why did he say i wouldn't use chocolate
as any way to describe someone's anus
but why did he say cadbury it's cadmium
kinder eggs were illegal in australia
for a really long time because they were
considered a choking hazard
same as america you have to have a
window on him because in him
americans would eat them
truthfully maybe that's what i'm
thinking of no i don't think i ever got
them here
the cadbury eggs have the cream inside
them
mm-hmm he is breaking up that word when
he marry i don't
cadbury cadbury what are you saying
cadbury were they they had a gorilla
they played the drums
phil collins he's not having a stroke
he's right
was that a cadbury ad yeah it was quite
viral
yeah they also had an eyebrow one i
think
these twins doing eyebrow i don't know
this girl and this boy doing these weird
eyes oh i've seen that one that doesn't
sound as cool as a gorilla playing the
drums no it's pretty good actually
how do we get here from my [ __ ] we're
still on chocolate
oh i see a chocolate let's see um
what what how would you compare his
bussy to like what like some salmon
sashimi
yeah yeah as doug describes it's very
salty
[Laughter]
he's dead he's going to watch this
friend in korea
we're just roasting him or become even
closer i would like to ask for next time
related to this because i do think it's
really fascinating and i found it very
fun when i was in japan and i've spoken
about it
can you uh make a note of any ads that
you find
particularly cool because we could
record if you find the ads and you can
find them on youtube or whatever we
could also watch
them if you want to do that or just let
us know keep an eye out for cool ads
because that stuff is super interesting
uh i had a tv in my last place and there
was this one
ad that i forget what the song it was
like a known song
but it wasn't a good song but the
person it was just like a picture of
them holding the product
and they just used like the after
effects puppet tool to like
move their head around and it was so
weird
and i'd love to find it again i don't i
have no idea what the product was or
anything
yeah it was so weird it makes me laugh
uh next month i think next time we
record this i'm going to be in amsterdam
cool what oh everywhere
well asia you know everyone's been doing
better with covet
except asia yeah asia it's been getting
worse
i don't think no it's like they had 100
uh cases in new south wales yesterday
and they're like ah
which for me i keep being like okay
that's not good and we don't want that
someone actually died of cover in the
last 24 hours in sydney oh no
which is very uncommon here but it's
just very weird coming from la where
we're like we have
900 cases today
all these vaccine and nobody who wants
them yeah whereas it's pretty still
pretty complicated to get them here it's
not as easy yeah john when when you're
in amsterdam by the way it's
it's not platonic company
can you ask ryan whiskey in amsterdam is
quite different
it's clear it's very different well i
will be staying in the
green lit areas
i hope so the green light in amsterdam
there is a
worker in amsterdam sitting with you and
you're showing him the same youtube clip
and they have a network they've got like
a facebook group and they're like this
[ __ ] guy
he's showing me the sweaty video he's
got the weirdest kink he shows
he makes us watch him on youtube dance
just keep doing it until it lands oh
just i just really
someone's gonna enjoy it episode one we
we really found out about
jacob twirling ribbons and then falling
down the streets [ __ ] hell
a sight i'm the
initial concept is like the the whole
abroad thing but
it's that's touched on for maybe like
five minutes i'm fine with it i do want
to talk about what you're up to but
really this is an excuse for
the four of us to catch up once a month
uh i'm planning to publish episodes on
the first monday of every month
so thank you everyone for watching our
first episode of idiots thank you
everyone
that's all right huge and the problem
we'll see you all next time
thank you